دونالد ترامب يائسًا من إعادة انتخابه
يائسًا لدرجة أنه على استعداد
لتهديد النقل السلمي للسلطة ،
لكن تقرير نيويورك تايمز الذي يكشف عن
رؤى من عقدين من إقراراته الضريبية
قد يلقي بعض الضوء على سبب
استعداد ترامب لتمزيق
كل معيار ديمقراطي  للاحتفاظ
بالسلطة كما
كتب أستاذ القانون بجامعة شيكاغو دانيال همل في منشور بواشنطن ،
فإن المخاطر على ترامب في الخريف
أكبر بكثير من
الرؤساء السابقين الذين كانوا يسعون لإعادة انتخابه ،
ولن تعني الخسارة نهاية
مهنة سياسية
فحسب ، بل وأيضًا  من المحتمل أن يكون الخراب الشخصي والمالي ،
كان رد الفعل الأول للكثيرين غاضبًا
من حقيقة أن الملياردير الشعبوي
المزعوم
يدفع ضرائب دخل فدرالية أقل من
العامل غير المتزوج بدوام كامل الذي يكسب
تسعة دولارات فقط في الساعة
وهذا نظام مزور ويجب إصلاحه
لكن إليكم ما قاله المفتش العام السابق للدوج
مايكل براونويتش
إذا خسر الانتخابات فسيواجه
محاكمة فيدرالية ومقاضاة على مستوى الولاية
بتهمة بنك فراو.  د الاحتيال الضريبي والاحتيال عبر البريد ،
لن تعفيه مذكرة olc من هذه
الأشياء الخطيرة
الآن ينطبق الاحتيال الضريبي على أي
مادة معرفية كاذبة في الإقرار الضريبي
مثل
تضخم الخسائر كاذبًا لدفع ضرائب أقل.
القروض الآن هذا ما قاله
مايكل كوهين ، الوسيط السابق لترامب ،
أمام الكونجرس في عام 2019. قام السيد ترامب بتضخيم
أصوله الإجمالية
عندما خدم أغراضه
مثل محاولة إدراجه بين
أغنى الأشخاص في فوربس
وتقليص أصوله لتقليل
ضرائبه العقارية منذ ذلك الحين
مانهاتن دا
قال إن ترامب قد يواجه تهم الاحتيال الضريبي ،
يبدو أن عظماء لعبة البيسبول بيت روز
وداريل فراولة فعل سجن ستينسون
لأقل بكثير الآن ، الإصدار الثاني ينبع
من جبل من الديون
وفقًا للأوقات التي كان
مسؤولاً فيها شخصياً عن القروض والديون الأخرى التي
يبلغ مجموعها 421 مليون دولار  مع
استحقاق معظمها في غضون أربع سنوات ،
لا نعرف لمن يدين الرئيس بكل
هذه الأموال
ولكنه يرفع قيمة r  المخاوف الحقيقية التي
يرى البعض أنها تمثل تهديدًا للأمن القومي ،
إليك ما تقوله إرشادات وكالة المخابرات المركزية إن
الفشل في العيش في حدود إمكانيات المرء
للوفاء بالديون والوفاء
بالالتزامات المالية قد يشير إلى
ضعف ضبط النفس ، أو الافتقار إلى الحكم أو
عدم الرغبة في الالتزام بالقواعد
واللوائح التي يمكن أن تثير جميعًا  الأسئلة حول
مصداقية الفرد وقدرته
على حماية المعلومات السرية أو الحساسة
تبدو الآن مثل أي شخص نعرفه
ولكن لا نخطئ في أن
هذا كله خطير بما يكفي لزيادة
إحساس ترامب باليأس من
بين أمور أخرى يهين تويتر المفضل لديه
كاذبًا كاذبًا كاذبًا خادعًا وفاشلًا مزيفًا
و  سيتقدم الخاسر إليه إلى الأبد
، وذلك قبل أن يتصل به الدائنون
والمدعون ، وهذا هو فحصك الواقعي